it's the Breakthrough their families
have been desperate for a man arrested
in connection with the brutal murder of
four University students a crime which
has tormented a town and mystified
America
housemates Kaylee gonsalves Madison
Logan and Zana canodle and zana's
boyfriend Ethan Chapin was stabbed to
death in their beds in this student home
in the small town of Moscow Idaho
after six weeks and with fears that this
case was going cold their suspected
killer was Tracked Down 2 500 miles away
in Pennsylvania
28 year old Brian coburger was a
criminology student at a nearby
University
Brian coburger
this video shows him graduating from
another University early this year
what I can tell you is we have a
individual in custody who committed
these horrible crimes and I do believe
our community is safe
one of the many unknowns pervading this
case is why the three-story house or its
occupants were targeted and why some
were left alive
on the first floor Zana and her
boyfriend Ethan who were sharing a bed
were killed
on the second floor Kaylee and lifelong
best friend Maddie also sharing a bed
were murdered two other female
housemates in ground floor bedrooms say
they slept through the attacks when they
woke they summoned other friends to the
house believing one housemate to be
unconscious police have ruled them out
as Suspects
police say they're still trying to build
the case against Cole Burger appealing
for the public to continue coming to
them with information this is not the
end of this investigation in fact this
is a new beginning
you all now know the name of the person
who's been charged with these offenses
please get that information out there
please ask the public anyone who knows
about this individual to come forward
call the tip line
furniture and other belongings were
removed from the crime scene today under
a top holding cover the process was
suddenly halted police say at the
request of the Court
but after six weeks with little sign of
any progress being made in this murder
inquiry Moscow police now believe they
have their man Martha Kellner Sky News